they're made the valid lanai even it's
1927 nanny we'll take care of marigold
and Anna can look after you really fancy
course highly anticipated will be
Downton Abbey I'm so excited about this
it's gonna hit theaters next month it's
just one of the many false movies that
people are excited about and we have
here Eric Davis managing director of
Fandango good morning let's talk about
danton Downton to start out yes we heard
that it broke some records did this
movie so popular its first day of
pre-sales on Fandango it outperformed
every other drama in 2019 including
films like Quentin Tarantino's Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood so it's like move
over leo and brad you ain't got nothing
on Downton Abbey folks still really love
these characters almost the entire cast
returning for a story that has the king
and queen coming to visit not the only
TV series that's becoming a movie -
Breaking Bad is getting a sequel movie
over on Netflix and The Sopranos is
getting a prequel movie next year the
many saints of Noah and then also this
is a bit of a TV - movie thing mr.
Rogers neighborhood yeah going to be
it's not a straight biopic it's not as
much like the documentary but it's more
about his relationship Fred Rogers
relationship with a journalist and Tom
Hanks plays mr. Rogers and I feel like
this is a role that he was born to play
look super emotional and the documentary
was emotional and we're living in sort
of this Fred Rogers Renaissance right
now where people are really coming to
appreciate it which I love because
there's a younger generation that did
not grow up with mr. right and Tom Hanks
is just brilliant I think in just about
everything that he does but it just
reminds us again how kindness and all
this authenticity matters that's what I
walked out of that movie very choked up
I'm very excited about hustlers I don't
expect to be choked just I'm really
excited about this mark my words this is
going to be one of the most entertaining
movies that you watch this entire why
in general what a Lopez Jennifer Lopez
Constance will my personal favorites
cardi B and Liz o have roles in them but
it's also based on a wild real-life
story about these exotic dancers who
hustled these Wall Street types you know
after the financial crisis in 2008 using
some nefarious tactics let's just say
but it's just fun it's got a lot of
style a lot of color a lot of great
music that way and it's JLo kind of
returning to form and she's great and if
you've got three and a half hours to
kill the Irishman maybe your movie is it
worth the investment oh I
Martin Scorsese reteaming with Robert
DeNiro and Joe Pesci they haven't made a
movie in 24 years the last one was
casino Al Pacino has never made a movie
with Scorsese so all of these guys look
I could watch these guys talk about
whacking guys for five hours the joke
are getting a lot of buzz too with
Joaquin get watch brother can't
reproduce it could be the Oscar
conversation this is going to be unlike
any comic book movie that you've seen of
late Scorsese it's inspired by King of
Comedy and thank you Eric we got to go
we'll be right back